fifteen seconds to play one Russell a
triple for D'Angelo Russell and
Russell's number and they're glad
tonight that this is preseason and not
the real deal this kids putting on a
show
[Music]
like I was trying to say coated steel
corrodes this is it Russell lays it in
Dinwiddie the penetration and kick crap
ball fake Russell it's a three and just
a good baseline drive by Spencer
Dinwiddie good extra drive one more
driving kick and gives them one of the
best lifts that Russell picked up by
Kuzma Russell
[Applause]
in the veins did and he's looking up
he's checking the clock he realizes
what's going on cruises hands are down
who's got space excellent rotation and
that is a clutch basket for D'Angelo
Russell against his former team and it's
huge really for a player like the Angelo
Russell lob it up Allen the catch
[Applause]
adjusts after the grab but great job
D'Angelo just making the right play as a
lower weak side got to foul and the file
did occur before Mike started his upward
motion but because of your right when
the whistle sounds Joe Harris gets
another easy one a little bit of quad
Davis the string underneath that screen
Neal he has punished him all the areas
he uses that Davis and then Bank
now the well it goes
stretching / dancing Russell
pull-up jumper is good
memory and soaking wet 36 to play fourth
quarter thanks Russell
a head and shoulder fake and the touch
he can finger roll very strong today's
hesitation doesn't carry the basketball
but once again from the floor to the to
the glass very quickly this one I
thought had a chance of actually missing
because of how high he went off the
glass one that he catches that right
polish Jefferson back to Russell Russell
waits till exams made eight points in
the quarter for DeAngelo Russell Nets in
front 103 to 99 the law Harris the catch
delivers beautiful set screen just then
they repair the mount prior as here he
starts on the right side coming around
the world and boom you can't catch up to
him
well-designed flash eight minutes to go
with the ball one your stuff yeah
exactly close
let it turn over Carol the layup timeout
Spurs it up to D'Angelo Russell thought
the screws
it's the bucket let's it to a one-point
game Darrell and to Daenerys
rustle in the face some Fournier that
man is unbelievable with that
three-point shot with pressure they get
Carolyn open look big time triple for
Davari carols with her Rosso
that shot and this is a guy that just
can really come into his own this season
big-time shot right here hi are ker
knocking it down this is a guy playing
with so much confidence right now
[Applause]
wonderful defense in the buff slips out
of the hands and goes through for
Russell great bow barbers running off
the line and Marvin they've hit the
right arm but he's left hand guys stop
and kg try to fight to Russell
this fall up trying to find out what's
going on [ __ ] DeMarre Carroll he's got
ahold of Michael kidd-gilchrist who's
trying to get over to screen to guard
Russell right there I mean that that's I
mean imagine what up Jimmy Chris he's a
Duke guy you're okay yeah you are
[Music]
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content